Hey, Thoughty2 here.
You’ve heard of snake charming; you may
have even hypnotised a chicken, but I bet
you’ve never heard of worm charming.
In what may be one of the most British events
in existence, every year the little village
of Willaston in Northern England hosts the
World Worm Charming Championships.
And yes, it is exactly what it sounds like,
charming worms out of the ground.
From chasing a wheel of cheese down a hill
to racing snails the British really do know
how to turn any old crap into a competitive
sport.
Every year hundreds of thrill-seekers gather
in the picturesque little village of Willaston
to compete in an intense championship of global
proportions.
The World Worm Charming Championships began
in 1980, when some village locals were so
bored that they decided to challenge each
other to coercing worms out of the ground
by rapidly tapping on the grass.
They thought it was so thrilling they made
a competition out of it and it has since grown
massively in popularity, some people travel
from all over Europe to attend.
So how does one charm a worm?
The basic idea is to create vibrations in
the ground which scares the worms to the surface.
Once they wiggle out of the ground, they must
be picked and placed into a plastic cup, this
is more difficult than it seems, if they’re
picked too soon or too fast, then it’s easy
to snap the worm in two.
Incomplete worms won’t be counted by the
judges.
Vibrations are created by all kinds of methods,
one of the most popular is jamming a pitchfork
into the soil and repeatedly hitting it to
send shockwaves into the ground.
Others opt for more unusual techniques such
as imitating the sound of rain, which worms
are naturally drawn towards, and even playing
the sound of rainfall into the soil.
Others simply resort to whacking the ground
with any random object that takes their fancy.
There was once a woman, who’s genuine technique
was to tap dance to the Star Wars theme song,
but she wasn’t able to turn them from the
dark side.
Aside from creating vibrations, moisture is
also a well-used technique.
Wetting the ground with things such as sugar
water, beer and even urine can help to coerce
the worms to the surface.
People create all kinds of strange mixtures
to use during the competition.
However, there’s a rule, nothing toxic is
allowed to be used and anyone using a liquid
must first take a gulp of it in front of the
competition’s official judge, the “Worm
Master”, before using it in the competition.
Nevertheless, people do still use urine.
Speaking of rules there are 18 of them in
worm charming, including: “Each competitor
is given a 3x3 metre plot”, “No digging
or forking is allowed” and “All worms
must be returned unharmed to the ground after
the competition”.
Each team is made up of three people: a Charmerer,
a Pickerer and a Counterer, and no I haven’t
said those wrongly, I’m fairly sure you
can guess what each of their roles are.
The current world record holder is a 10-year-old
girl, who charmed 567 worms from the ground
during the World Worm Charming Championships
in 2009.
But the weird world of worm charming isn’t
just reserved to an eccentric village in the
North of England, believe it or not there’s
another British village that is totally obsessed
with worm charming.
Every year Blackawton, a village stuck to
the bottom of Britain’s big toe, otherwise
known as Devon, hosts a worm-charming festival.
The Blackawton International Festival of Wormcharming
is similar to its Northern brother but festivities
include live music all weekend and unlike
the 3 square metres provided at the World
Championships, contestants at Blackawton only
get a measly 1 square metre to do their charming.
Fancy dress is also not an uncommon sight
at the festival.
The Blackawton festival also has an “Official
Cheat” who’s job is to encourage and even
help others to cheat, often selling “black
market” worms to contestants, to boost their
score.
Despite the fact that the rules state “any
competitor caught cheating will be publically
humiliated and disqualified”.
One competitor was banned for life because
he concealed worms up his trouser leg before
the event, so he could sprinkle them onto
the ground.
You’ve really got to admire someone who
would risk worms sliming up their most personal
of spaces, just to win a village competition.
Thanks for watching.